oh my god that was so bad Sean and is
still burning I'm gonna feel that one
tonight
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter ways and today
we're doing a quarantine special with
our buddy comedian Bert Kreischer he has
a special on Netflix the trending hey
big boy also check out the Berk cast
something's burning on YouTube as well
as two bears one cave a podcast he does
alongside fellow friend of the brand Tom
Segura Bert Kreischer thanks for joining
me for this very special hot ones
quarantine edition I am so excited I
can't tell you part of me feels like I'm
gonna over saturate my wings I can
already feel it well you know it's do it
ourselves here today I know I had wings
delivered about an hour ago they sent
the sauces over to your house so we're
just like kind of on the honor system
here I got everything oh dude first of
all you know for a fact people are gonna
talk [ __ ] [ __ ] and you go oh they even
didn't put any sauce on it he's doing it
himself
bro I'm loading these wings up
[Music]
[Music]
slide the phone out you see the steam
coming off of it here we go
fresh mmm nice
[Music]
so I suppose we should start with the
goofy reason why we're doing this
interview over the Internet which is
obviously this corona pandemic and the
quarantine have you given any thought to
what this all means for stand up I heard
you make an interesting point on the
podcast where you called the quarantine
like a reset button for comedians it's
going to redefine touring for a lot of
comics a lot of comics are gonna look at
it and and you look at it you go there's
400 touring comics and theaters right
well those all those foreign comics are
gonna be struggling to get the same four
theaters at the last six months five
months of the year that means 200 comics
that are theater acts are going to clubs
that means 200 club comics that are high
level Club comics are getting their
money docked and they're going down to
fallout weekends that means guys like
myself and segura who 10 years ago we're
getting opportunities aren't getting
opportunities and by the way we're also
talking about comedy clubs their rents
are like probably 25 grand 30 grand in
these shopping malls they're not gonna
be able to pay their rents the onus is
on guys like myself bill burr Tom Segura
Joe Rogan Joey Diaz all these guys that
are doing bigger numbers to go into
these comedy clubs on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and make sure that make sure
that they can pay their mortgages make
sure that they can pay their rents and
make sure that all these wait staffs can
pay their bills I'm gonna turn my phone
off hold on lovely just unplug it who
has a landline I'll tell you what
landlines and guns come in handy during
these quarantines huh
come a palooka Lika whoa that comes out
quick holy crap
I just blew copied this link this looks
like it's gonna be sweet yeah buh buh
now perfectly done so I might surprise
you
sneaky heat yeah oh you needed yeah but
I put on it oh [ __ ] without my computer
I doused that holy [ __ ] so I want to
stay on the topic of coronavirus and
comedy because you know what you've seen
a lot of sports teams do is experiment
with this idea of having games with no
fans in the stands or you see like
WrestleMania and a completely empty
arena does that translate to comedy like
would recording a Netflix comedy special
under those conditions even be something
you could do well speaking as a guy who
used to do comedy with no fans in the
audience all do mm no it doesn't work
there's a guy online and I'm not gonna
say his name but he's like a comic and
he did he does every day he does 10
minutes of stand-up just right to a mic
but once again he's him in his house
he's got a black sheet that clearly he's
jacked off on a couple of times it's
like watching a crazy person unravel my
biggest fear in the world isn't like me
- it's not it's not anything anything
bad my biggest fear is is someone one
day is gonna take this camera and stream
me masturbating that's my biggest fear
is that you will see me unmasked just
sitting there readers on just
and that is my fear and that's what
doing stand-up by yourself looks like
looks like you they caught you
masturbating
Berndt I know you have a party animal
reputation but I take comfort in the
fact that you're just as comfortable and
happy at home watching TV have you had a
chance to see precious gems since your
interview with Adam Sandler did you see
that interview I did I did oh how
cringe-worthy was that I thought it was
kind of charming it was extremely Burt
this is how oblivious I am Sean I didn't
even realize I did what I did I
literally walked out got my Karim was
like that went great I literally thought
to myself that went great
and and the head writer for my Netflix
series cabin my Gibbons called me and he
said that was hilarious and I was like
yeah I was like I didn't know if is that
funny and he was like are you kidding me
you asked him if he had [ __ ] Netflix
and I went well yeah right he goes Burt
he's got a two hundred million dollar
deal at Netflix yeah they'd throw that
in and I went oh yeah that was a dumb
question he goes that was a dumb
question he goes do you realize you
called it happy Madison you called it
precious gems and then you said what
movie would you work on for the rest
here like you oh yeah that didn't go so
good he goes that didn't go so good all
sudden my other phone rings on my like
the other call-waiting rings is Jay
oakerson Jay oakerson is dying laughing
he's like you made a fool of yourself
for the better part of 10 minutes and I
was like was it that bad he goes oh bro
I cut it together I could not watch the
parts they were talking about cuz I had
no recollection I thought it went off so
smoothly I didn't even know I had [ __ ]
up and that dude thank God Adam
Sandler's a king because not only did he
watch my set special but he came out and
said that he enjoyed it he had that nice
tweet about it dude that was the [ __ ]
greatest I wonder part of him was like f
[ __ ] it he seems like a nice guy like I
wasn't a dick I was just an idiot
[Music]
that's a good sauce that's a really good
sauce this might be a keeper this is a
good whoa this is a good on ribs on on a
nice on a nice brisket sandwich sauce
this is down on this goes over to the
side I like that one a lot for your
adventures in parenting to teenage girls
they've been well-documented throughout
your stand-up specials over the years I
understand that you've taken the role of
PE teacher during this stretch of
homeschooling but can you paint the
picture for me like what does gym class
look like with Coach Kreischer gym class
with Coach visor starts with a whistle
we have a trade off we can do 15 minutes
of calisthenics which is jumping jacks
deep knee bends the Hindu get-ups
or you can do three miles on the
treadmill what's a lunch lady Burt
serving up in the at-home cafeteria bro
I think killer [ __ ] sandwiches I have
really taken my sandwich to the next
level I make an egg perfectly fluffy the
way that Gordon Ramsay taught you how
beautiful little creme fraiche in it I
take bacon I put it in the oven I cook
it at 420 right get it nice and melty
fresh avocados cheese great breads I've
done croissants I've done baggy I've
done all great breads
toting the toaster toast it up man my
breakfast sandwich games on lock gave it
to Georgia she was like oh my god like I
in my head I go enough of those
sandwiches is she won't do drugs
oh I am putting a lot of hot sauce on
these wings Sean we're doing it for the
people today I mean look at these these
bones are sliding out these are perfect
is a veteran over here not his first
wing wow this is awesome this one's
[ __ ] great all right Bert as you know
in the five spot we have a recurring
segment called explain that Graham we do
a deep dive on our guests Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context I think maybe I'll just like
text these things to you but maybe you
already know what I'm talking about
anyway
if you show it to me I should know it
first up is uh you know one of these
videos where you're around a bajillion
fans and no I usually went to your last
show here in New York probably one of
like the last comedy shows before this
whole thing hit and you always do this
thing where you'll invite everybody
who's at the show and I think you did
two sold-out shows that night at the
Beacon Theater has that ever backfired
on you when you just blitz some dive bar
in a local town with like a hundreds of
people from your show oh yeah it
backfires a lot fun I imagine it would
sometimes they're massively grateful if
you go to a place like like we were in I
think we're in Winnipeg and I was like
fantastic we'll go to this bar everyone
goes or Calgary we're in Calgary send
everyone over to a bar it was like one
of those like Max and Emmas you know
type bars where it's like a little
little corporate huge lots of space go
in they're loving you they're like dude
you made our night but you go into those
bars like a bar and you know Pittsburgh
and it's just some chick throat tattoo
go and get the [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
who you are [ __ ] beat it oddly enough
I actually ran into you at this event -
here you are at the Kings game that's
right what do you think is your single
greatest Jumbotron moment of all time
I think it'd have to be that Kings game
without a doubt I mean I got was I I got
some tarps off tarps off for the boys
because when as soon as the camera went
to me I threw my shirt off and the
hockey player looked at me I said tarps
off for the boys and he started laughing
a toothless laugh and I was like oh bro
that's all I need
the last one is the dance battle the
famous dance battle that you had with
Tom Segura
dancing to post Malone's Wow what's your
honest assessment of that dance battle
and then were you surprised by anyone
who reached out to you after the fact I
did think it was cool that like Tom got
an actual cosign from Missy Elliott
Tom's was awesome man I was blown away
by how much he put into it because it
was just so much bigger than mine
like syllabi got a high budget music
video or something yeah I never got a
shout-out for clothes blown you [ __ ]
believe that
I mean I'm sure I didn't really
celebrate his work the way he wanted to
be celebrated sure he saw that it was
like why am I supposed to like this the
guy's fat as [ __ ] all right Bert are you
ready to move on back half here yup
Thai green sauce Thai green sauce and
the six spot I love it all right I'm
going to I'm going to a leg whoa
these are running out hot men
[Music]
I like this one that so during simpler
times recently you went to a Los Angeles
Wildcats game with Bill burr how did the
fan experience of the XFL compared to
say like seeing the Rams play Monday
Night Football at the Coliseum BER is
not he's a very nice guy he's very
generous to his fans but he's you know
in a we raised kind of blend in a bull
he blends in you know he's got a shaved
head he's got a beard he's got his hat
on but it's not hat isn't like like a
good-looking hat it's like a Nike golf
hat like you know it's just like a
regular person's hat so he kind of
blends in I on the other hand and like
half shirtless half the time I'm loud as
[ __ ] bill kept going you got to stop
matching their [ __ ] energy he's like
they recognize you and you get more
excited than they get you're like oh
shut up on the machine and your shirt
comes off he's like [ __ ] stop that
just so hey thank you and take the
picture I was like yeah yeah yeah it was
awesome dude we had a great time the
food was awesome I wanted to do a
halftime show to promote my special one
game I was gonna go to and in right at
halftime
are you gonna hear loud the guy in the
loud announcer go ladies and gentlemen
today's halftime presentation is brought
to you by comedian Bert Kreischer his
special hey Big Boi is currently
streaming on Netflix make sure to check
it out and tell your friends sit back
and enjoy oh my god it's a streaker and
then I was gonna run out make it right
have the cops chase me cops are chasing
me they tackle me on the center-field
right and all of a sudden you hear duh
duh duh duh duh duh duh duh duh duh
night and we all stand up right young
man there's no need to and you know the
whole crowd would go nuts oh I was so
excited the XFL was coming to my beacon
game and then you know my beacon show in
New York and then [ __ ] went sideways so
maybe next season or I'll do it for the
Rams
all right I got a doused this one's a
little thicker of sauce oh yeah oh oh
[ __ ] yeah everything else has been
[ __ ] around until now Oh gloves are
off we're at altitude so hip-hop has
been kind of dominating the quarantine
between Drake songs made for tick tock
and then these DJ battles that are going
on with Instagram live yes Dave
Chappelle once said that every comedian
wants to be a rapper and every rapper
thinks they're funny a hundred percent a
hundred percent dude I write lyrics in
earnest
I sang them on our podcast - there's one
cave last week man I love I Spit bars I
hate my favorite rapper that I get a
kick out of him hardcore is uh Trinidad
James dude there's no better feeling
than to be playing all gold everything
windows down and pulling up to softball
to pick up your daughter and watch her
just crumble MJG an 8-ball alcohol [ __ ]
and weed one of my favorite songs to
pull up picking my kids look up to
alcohol [ __ ] and weed once alcohol
[ __ ] and weed twice I mean I'm like on
the [ __ ] floor all right Burt are you
ready to move on to the 8th spot you
know this one well I believe the bomb
beyond insanity this one's no joke man
every time anyone says anything about
hot ones they go what's the sauce this
is the sauce that that legit it does
push up the right way
I put a healthy amount on I'm now
pulling it off like any respectable
adult all right this is gonna hurt
tomorrow morning this is gonna be the
one that gets me up at 4:00 in the
morning
sitting on my squatty potty whoa
oh it already perfect
[Music]
all right you're a man who's
well-connected well-loved in comedy so
if you'll humor me I want to throw some
comedy world superlatives off of you and
you just tell me the first person who
comes to mind and why oh [ __ ] dude I had
way too much on that one who's most
likely to make national headlines
getting beat up by the mainstream media
for a corona joke how you gonna get beat
up oh my god I can't even [ __ ] think
son
oh it just got so [ __ ] real don't
touch your face don't touch your eyes I
know it's the [ __ ] coronavirus I'm
not touching Haley you know it's gonna
be it's gonna be a cloud chaser and
they'll be looking for exam I'll tell
you who it is Adam hunter Adam hunter
you've I don't know who he is I'm sorry
Adam but he doesn't give a [ __ ] Ari
Shaffir what the [ __ ] am I talking about
always appear good Ari Shaffir is
getting beat up no it's always a beer
which comedian besides yourself and Tom
do you think at the best hot ones
episode Joey Diaz without a [ __ ]
doubt Joey be a classic after son I
gotta give a shout-out to Chris D'Elia
use the original comedian on hot ones
like what deep TJ Miller was pretty
amazing but D'Elia was like [ __ ]
comedians seem to be more Fitness
obsessed than they ever have been before
it was most likely to come out of
isolation looking like they stepped out
of boot camp Burke aye sir I'm working
out like buggin crazy but I'm not
drinking that's why I'm eating like a
[ __ ] Savage oh my god Sean I put way
too much I heard you say that's it you
went whoa and I was like what but that's
very burnt going a hundred miles per
hour through the intersection red light
or not I have a problem with impulse
I'll tell you is gonna be the fattest
comment coming out its agura so there is
eating like crazy bro he calls me he's
like I can't stop eating cupcakes I'm
like for real he's like yeah man
I'm like who's making cupcakes he's like
I'm breaking Gordon team go to the store
oh my god that was so [ __ ] bad Sean
it is still burning I'm gonna feel that
one tonight
holy [ __ ] I'm not even stopped down from
the last one
Oh God all right here we go
it's going down
oh I'm still burning from the bomb
uh-uh right here we go oh are you having
coffee huh no I'm just drinking uh some
ice water out of this pucker buff mug
I'm gonna live by myself guy I just have
mugs and like three spoons Oh Bert last
year you optioned the rights to your
story the machine for a feature film has
the rise of the Machine and everything
that happens since you first told it
officially become more unbelievable than
the experience that inspired it I feel
like I can't believe that story's got
that kind of legs like there was a time
where is like if I had quit doing comedy
I don't think anyone would have noticed
like they would have been like oh I
didn't even know that you didn't do it
anymore
so to have anyone care that you have a
joke let alone be like I mean at the end
of every show there you like flying
dildos Tracy Morgan the Machine
ziplining in your like and I think this
is the difference between telling jokes
like set up plunge and doing stories
like when you do a story I think it's
ever-changing it's always kind of
morphing like a little bit like a jam
band and I think that's what people
enjoy about I think I don't know I don't
know I'll keep telling as long as they
want to hear it I'll keep telling it all
right Bert Kreischer will last them
look at this [ __ ] plate Shawn look at
this plate it looks like a murder while
wow what is a crime sealed all over the
[ __ ] thing again I just got my pants
all then alright the last tab do you
remember when Coolio put this [ __ ] I
mean I remember that so vividly I'll
never forget that to have it all up a
tad bit rub it in alright here we go
I'm records big boy cheers big ears
Thank You Shawn
Faulk me all right Bert here we are at
the top of mount Scoville a bajillion
scovilles threatening to short-circuit
this zoom chat that we're doing over the
Internet
so now that we're here what's your
message to the people out there who
might be feeling a little bit down a
little bit anxious a little bit
alienated and these uncertain times I
think the people need the calming
influence of Bert Kreischer the people's
comedian there's not about hard work
people you know what it is you watch
these inspirational people on Instagram
that are like it's about get out of bed
get up it's 5:45 in the morning start
doing kettle bells not today guys it's
about staying at home sometimes the best
workout you can do is not getting on the
treadmill it's about staying home and
taking half a xanax and watching Blazing
Saddles
and taking the time to learn how to make
bread or learn how to make pizza dough
you know god damn look hard works great
you need our work you need a work ethic
but every now and then you gotta be the
guy that goes that's it I'm calling it a
night then you go [ __ ] it so stay home
and get lucky
sometimes you gotta take your foot off
the gas pedal and those are words to
live by from Bert Kreischer and look at
you my man
our famous fan in early classic hot ones
in 2016 and here we are with the
quarantine special for the people here
in 2020 and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
my friend
this camera this camera only one camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life if you are stuck at home
I hope that I can treat you to some
comedy turn on Netflix and watch hey big
boy streaming right now it is my four
special my third one on Netflix on
Netflix you can find secret time and the
machine where I tell the story about
getting involved with the Russian mafia
and robbing a train when I was 22 but
more importantly check out hey big boy
streaming right now on Netflix Sean I
love you you've created somebody to
intent for me to sit back and enjoy
during this quarantine thank you thank
you thank you I got you on my DVR on
truTV I'm watching hot ones a game show
every [ __ ] night god bless you
brothers stay safe all right love you
bird thank you so much for Dylan you too
Sean
[Music]
Oh bro it's my favorite thing I ever get
recognized for people say you know oh I
love you Netflix special I love you on
Rogan
oh I follow the podcast you always like
really but when they say hot ones I go
because I know that they've watched mine
they've watched all of them like I have
and we immediately pick up Mike what did
you think of the Russell Brand episode
and they're like oh my god almost as
good as Ricky Gervais
I go hold on Margot Robbie and they're
like dude the best one you've done Paul
Rudd I fell in love with Paul Rudd look
I was thanking me but with Paul Rudd my
entire life I was like I get it I guess
maybe his uncle who owns a studio I
don't know how he got him and Mark
Ruffalo how did they get folded into it
I get it but man that episode with Paul
Rudd I fell in love with him dude
yesterday was his birthday he turned 51
and I was like everything he does is
great he turned 51 like now I feel young
because of Paul Rudd well they said the
bomb here's corona but you got to put it
in your [ __ ] would you do it hey
what's going on hot ones fans this is
Sean Evans checking in with a very
exciting sauce update now as I'm sure
you're aware we have a new show hot ones
the game show on truTV featuring sauces
that are off the charts hot I'm talking
about the brain burner the eye of the
Scorpion the constrictor all extreme
heat with beautiful labels designed by
tattoo artists of note and guess what
they can be yours
that's right brain burner I have the
Scorpion the constrictor they're all
available at heat Ness calm heat nice
calm heat nice calm to order and don't
forget to check out hot ones The Game
Show Tuesdays 10:00 p.m. Eastern 9
central on truTV live the show if you
dare bring the pepper dome to your
living room
and remember milkshakes are for winners
only
[Music]